I think I'm a human being who has ideas
hypothesis and opinions ideas hypothesis
and opinions if I can and passion am i
hot
I'm just IHOP I'm ideas hypotheses
opinions and passion I'm the new [ __ ]
I hope you got your perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is another episode with gary vee
super excited i am here on this
beautiful Thursday morning I hope
everybody super well looking forward to
the questions dozen I don't see any
questions in the queue but I'll be ready
for that in a second
nonetheless everybody's super well hope
everybody's hanging in obviously it's a
challenging time for a lot of people and
so hopefully we can give some Q&A here
that brings some value to people my
friend a town called me this morning
told me this shows not good enough and
it's not retaining enough so I'm gonna
try to give better answers than ever so
let's rock and roll any time just
kidding I love you bro Lucas Lucas
what's good what's going on Gary how are
you I'm well what can I help you with
thanks for taking the time out of your
day I really appreciate this happy to do
it ma'am so just to give you a little
bit of context I'm a photographer I have
a YouTube channel where I document my
process more on the side of film
photography okay so essentially the main
premise of the channel is based around
one show called value shooters go to the
thrift store I pick up a 35-millimeter
camera I like that's undervalued and I
shoot with it review it and then I give
it away to a member of the community
after it's all done love that concept
thank you
it's honestly it's inspired from
everything that you do that hence the
name value shooters and it kind of
coincides with Value Village which is
kind of cool but while I'm there I'm
also grabbing stuff to flip on ebay
which is another cool thing because like
now that everyone's staying inside eBay
stuff is flying off the shelves but my
question is what it like is it too early
for the ask like I'm pretty early in the
process I'm super patient I'm not in a
rush at all not trying to look at like
subs or anything so then the answer is
yes if like if that's your mentality
right
that means the longer you hold out what
he asked the better garter so a lot of
people can't hold out for the ask right
yesterday we had some people on to you
with Gary B who the musicians are so in
trouble and I told her to flip it and do
you know donations cuz like they had to
go for ask right away yeah you're in a
place where you're like you know it's
funny you picking up stuff at those
places to flip on eBay is almost paying
for your ability to not go in three ask
no different than my public speaking
allows me to not have to go and he asked
for my audience and I think that's a
really great model I think one of the
things that makes me stand out from a
lot of people is I'm not trying as you
know you know how long have you been
following me just over a year baby right
so that first day you find me like much
like other characters on the internet
all sorts you're like hey where's when's
the shoe gonna drop when's he gonna ask
me for something like I get that email
all the time like waiting for the shoe
drop waiting for the shoe to drop but I
don't need to and that's what builds a
real brand and I think it's okay to go
in for the ask I think it's very ok if
you want to sell something or do
something it's what I want to sell
empathy when I want to sell k-swiss I'm
pumped with that it's always okay I
think the longer you can hold off by not
asking the better
I see cuz I'm not really a big on like
patreon or anything like I want to still
provide value with the ask I agree bro
you know empathy is a $45 wine yeah I
feel thrilled buying that but like for
20 bucks
like if somebody buys a pair of caseless
like you know like I'm gonna buy another
pair of sneakers anyway it's not like
I'm making them spend something right
legging and on the marketing stuff it's
free for life so like you know I think
that I think you've got the right
mindset brother keep going holding your
breath bringing the most value possibly
you can to your audience without asking
for their money is the greatest leverage
point if you can if you can subsidize
through flipping on eBay and YouTube ads
for the rest of your life and never have
to ask them for something amazing
or if you ask them for something it's
something high value like access like a
weekend with you you know shooting in
the in the woods for a week and it's
experience
five thousand dollars a head you can
almost go super premium once you go to
brand so that's how I'm thinking yeah
I'm not getting any money on ads I'm
gonna still patient with that any what
so you're not gonna use yeah I'm not a
good boy I picked up a job to kind of so
I'm doing that like full-time almost 40
hours a week I'm living on my parents so
I just finished college
what do you live just like an hour
outside of Toronto understand fantastic
so it's just about the pace now I like
the pong you got I like being I like the
ingredients you got it are you doing
tick-tock
yes sir how many a day don't lie cuz
we're [ __ ] left and we'll call you
know honestly honestly not a lot but now
I'm kind of I hit one that got pretty
big and then I got lazy because I'm like
oh now I got you're not off like you're
like not really but and now I'm trying
to put like one a day at least but it's
not pertaining to what I do on YouTube
so I'm trying to express exactly pertain
to what you're doing that you're
passionate about okay when you do for a
day you can do two that are pertaining
to [ __ ] camera life and you can do
one to flip life and you can one do one
to having [ __ ] epic hair yeah thanks
do you think I should do flip life stuff
like on the photography Channel too
because I don't want to bombard people
with like content you should try it I
think you should try it you know people
like you know when I do garage saling
when I do marketing when I do wine like
are there a group of people like I don't
want to hear about wine I'm here to get
[ __ ] tips to build my business I'm
like sorry dude but like the next post
is coming father so you know like people
are crippled by one piece of content I'm
not I agree I don't feel that way either
cuz I post a bunch of [ __ ] that I do on
a regular basis like when I go but
you're so good yes I do a bunch of [ __ ]
and they obviously do as well as the
photo stuff but I don't care about that
you shouldn't because what ends up
happening is it's building a depth with
a certain group of people with you and
that's great
so I would I think you've been man keep
it going I appreciate this man
take care all right big shout out
actually before we go
big big big shout out to Jack Kapp with
two T's on Twitter I didn't even have to
remind him to share the askgaryvee show
on twitter as a matter of fact I just
followed you Jack in Bristol England and
retweeted your share please take a
screenshot of this right now and share
it on your platforms it's get a ton of
people to watch today I'm following on
Twitter not enough for you tweeting me
right now so I need that Oh big shot of
Jack Jake Jase Dean as well
Perla Rivera I'm retweeting both of you
this is a this is I love this rish with
Republic of cellars
I'm retweeting all of you I guys I want
you guys to get tons of $20 and there
she is
Maria what is good hi Gary how are you
I'm really well how are you good I'm
also from New Jersey
what part Toms River right now love it
yeah if it wasn't for you I wouldn't
even be here asking this question right
now
part of the wrestling community I know
you like wrestling too
I started a podcast with a friend and I
loved it more than I didn't know I was
gonna love it more than exactly more
than my job more than everything I loved
it um I look forward to doing all the
time my question to you is how do I have
a decent following in the wrestling
community on Twitter only how do I get
it out there to more people more on
Twitter and mortgages in the world in
general like I don't know first you put
use your Twitter to start building up
the other
the platform's you have to get on
tick-tock and Instagram yesterday have
you talked to Rick I would argue that
tick-tock is your biggest opportunity
for people that don't have big audiences
in the macro the biggest opportunity is
to be a first mover in an emerging
platform and tik-tok is still emerging
even at its enormous scale yeah I mean I
think you should do to wrestling just
like right now like talk about wrestling
women like which is not and then just
like learn tick-tock go - tick-tock
today and spend an hour or two just
consuming tick-tock to get a feel for
the room and then start making the next
day yeah - 2 cups a day and then use
Twitter because Twitter is amazing you
can tweet 30 times a day and get away
with it so use Twitter to build up your
tick-tock and your Instagram I would
probably pick four to five tweets a day
per platforms that's ten tweets a day
pushing to your Instagram and your tick
touch they can siphon some of your
audience there and then you just start
building within those worlds that's the
way you migrate audience that gives use
a little spark by like using Twitter is
the best platform to have most your
users because you can use it to push to
the other places whereas on Instagram
you can't post 15 times a day you can
use stories but you need to get very
serious about those two platforms it
will work Twitter and tick tock on
Twitter Instagram and tick tock using
Twitter to build up there on Twitter or
jumping are you jumping in to random
wrestling conversations and adding your
two cents good all day long more more
more more like literally just you know
search and Big John Studd Rey Mysterio
like W like just search and jump in jump
in jump in and I i'll ask questions and
i'll get a lot of responses not dying no
asking questions now or community you
know I want you to I want more people
discover you so I want you to go on
Twitter right and I'll show you actually
this is fun now they have time so I'm
going to put it right now and I'm
literally gonna type in ECW right
wrestling right and when when I type
that you know
something's come up I hit I like to hit
latest at the top latest so he hit
latest on ECW and what you see is you
know 34 minutes ago somebody says in the
last 24 hours I've watched a e/w
dynamite the rise and fall of ECW click
from NXT and the wrestlers episode 1 you
know this reason and I can just reply
and I just replied I literally am
replying to this person right now let
you know I don't that I don't know what
Twitter is the cocktail party of the
Internet
well here's my problem with Twitter
because doing that and I follow you for
two years and I shouldn't feel that way
and it takes a lot for me but the amount
of haters that you get well yeah I know
what is a bizarre the reason people
didn't like high school haters are the
reason people don't like life like other
people's opinions are dog [ __ ] [ __ ] man
if somebody's not this is like old
school and keep like old school grandma
[ __ ] if you jump into that conversation
and they're like let's go to the most
extreme
shut up [ __ ] just move on what you're
worried that [ __ ] big john studd 49
called you a [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] loser if he would do that I feel
bad for him don't feel bad for yourself
feel bad for him Rhea this is the number
one [ __ ] mental thing Twitter is the
cocktail party of the Internet
you should be jumping into 50 to 500
wrestling conversations a day on Twitter
because you're knowledgeable and when
somebody says something about repo-man
you bring up something about demolition
okay I know as we've shown my nerd
Russell you know okay yeah I'm a little
bit but but nonetheless got it got it
Instagram tick tock I need to see four
posts from you today on those two
platforms and you see jumping into 50
conversations about aw about Triple H
about missing China I'm missing about
whatever the heck is on your mind
jump search search in there and get in
there you know search you know Brock
Lesnar the name and then people are
talking jump in there right
got it search me anymore in and jump in
there and add your two cents search
Gronkowski and add your two cents that
you think he's a doof cuz he's a [ __ ]
patriot I [ __ ] hate him Boyd he's
entertaining and glad he's I'm glad he's
retired but do you know what I mean add
your two cents and somebody says you
don't know anything and this and that
drop knowledge on them you know Elsie
good luck me thank thank you you're
welcome a big shout-out to my dad's
business wine Tex actually actually team
I know you've been asking about lower
thirds like I don't mind putting wine
texts on here he it is exploding wine
Tex calm if you're not part of it and
you buy wine get on it and plus now
everybody's buying the wine on the
Internet wine text comm sign up we mean
the world to me
because it would support my dad Sean
your hair looks good don't worry bro
let's rock and roll thank you so much
for having me on man I really appreciate
it man I don't know if you remember you
send me an email back in January I sent
you an email about like some stuff I had
going on you sent me like this whole
thing and you said you're gonna win and
I was like that's been my whole motto
for this year man so I really appreciate
it man I do remember you know it's funny
back to the joke I need to start the
show
my buddy eight tons like hey you need to
do more and I'm like bro I do so many
things behind the scenes me and Lou sent
a master to hospitals all around the
country I'm one on one replying to
people at midnight on my text to one two
nine three one five seven three one I
want to remind everybody before you know
that so many of us are doing so many
things behind us things as well so like
rock and roll so like just like that
back in January just sending that so I
appreciate it watching yesterday and if
you weren't watching today you missed
out but just so my question is like just
further interviewed like what communes
do to be successful at this time like
you talked about doing a live streams
and throwing up the link to the bin low
and stuff like that but I guess some of
the concern I've heard from like other
artists
stuff is like the wells gonna run dry
after a certain amount of time and like
my argument is after watching you for
four years that if you provide good
content like people are gonna keep like
the cream is gonna rise to the top
that's so like is there anything you
feel like I can do to try to differ
differentiate myself I guess from being
anything is going on of course being
your honest self I think the biggest
differentiator is actually more
authentically and more transparency
there is only one Sean Mullan like like
your insecurities sharing that with the
audience only you can do that right you
know like the way your voice sounds only
you can do that the way you play it
only you can do that I I pretty much
suck at everything besides being fully
Gary Vaynerchuk and and that means a
garage sale which confuses people and
that means that I stay private with the
things that I'm most proud of when I
help and donate and things thanks sure
and it means that I prefer to do
one-on-ones like this instead of you
know Jay being with other famous like
I'm just best Abita that means I'm going
to talk about sports cards and I'm
willing to hustle 15 hours a day
and I'm going to talk about the Jets and
and he Petrie bands 100% no matter what
train and love my family and support in
sports and AJ like like I'm me and I
think the biggest thing that people I'm
me in a world where I watch people
trying to be somebody anybody besides
themselves I'm gonna be like oh I love
what that person did I'm gonna be more
like them or I need to be do more what I
don't [ __ ] I want to do what anybody's
doing I don't give a [ __ ] about them you
know how to break out you know how to be
different by being different everybody
else just try to be like somebody else
I'm trying to be Gary [ __ ] Vaynerchuk
it's just it'sit's overwhelming man like
just watching you for four years and
like man I've gone through some tough
stuff man and like you know it's just
like all the different quotes that you
have and like I've posted stuff up in
the room
like different clothes that you have
just to like to motivate me to keep
going like when I have a bad day
especially now after getting that email
like the first thing he said is you're
gonna win and like every time like
things get a little bit down I'm like
I'm gonna win man and Gary said I'm
gonna win I'm gonna get this I keep
driving you know yes yes I do know and
you're so young dude how old are you I'm
33 takes me 34 if you actually under do
you know at 34 is when I left to start a
nerd media I know man I think about that
a lot
I'm like man this could be the time you
know and by the way and maybe for you
the time is 46 and guess what you'll
still have 50 [ __ ] more years to live
after 46 we need to change this age as a
mindset we do not have a good
relationship with time in the world
everyone thinks it's all running out 33
is a [ __ ] baby
I texted a bunch of people in my text
platform last night that were like 68 to
72 and I just send them a message of
like we got 30 more years of [ __ ]
damage and it was funny that replies
they said me and like but they get it
like do you know what a 68 year old
thinks about how young you are they're
like mother [ __ ]
I got she's older this [ __ ] mm-hmm
yeah cuz I look back at ages I've done
before and I'm like man if I'd realize
how much time then I'm like well I'm
probably gonna think that later about
this time so I should just go ahead and
write you now I love where your mind is
man keep pushing better I love you you
know make the content about you more
truth those those hard times get that
poison out of your body cuz a lot of
people will associate with you on that
it'll be therapeutic for you and it will
make a connection point with others
there's only one you bro that's the only
way to break through you said it man
thank you so much you're welcome so much
everybody's watching hope I'm sorry
getting some of this getting some
doesn't stuff I'm really doesn't let's
see who's sharing there we go I see some
sharing all right Adam chime Preston
Alexander you're getting shared let's go
put screenshots and links to
here we go Alex saying good for you like
that
Steven Stanwood I agree that's a good
quote Matthew agents good bro Gary how
you doing my man I'm doing well thank
you so much for taking the time doing
this I feel inspired and grateful for
this for sure probably do it thank you
um so I'm I'm an elementary education
major at the University of Iowa and at
the December of 2018 I started my
podcast called be kind be positive be
yourself just because 2018 was like the
first time I experienced like hard
anxiety and fallen depression and that I
wanted to start and break up with the
girl I thought it was and I had never I
had to figure myself out mm-hmm and
everything and I want to is more
therapeutic to start my podcast for
myself when you've asked forward to now
and we built a community and a lot of
people and a lot of connections I never
thought I would have and uh you know you
take all the time and I I look at you as
a role model because you use your
platform empathy optimism positivity as
making it cool right and you lead you
lead with it and I really respect you
for that and that's what I'm trying to
do so my question is people that are in
a pessimistic route or kind of down on
the times right how do I encourage them
and lead them with positivity without
coming off as rude or overbearing or
anything just yeah and and and this is
an aggressive motion so I'll give it to
you a different way like okay or bro
it's just consistency in consistent
conversation in perpetuity mmm probably
been doing this for a minute and I'm
going to do it when I'm 107 and it's
gonna be consistent and people don't
leave comments and whatever form
comments are in 25 years saying you say
the same [ __ ] dick dick do you
understand how do you do it by you
staying consistent by you having
perspective and then how do you do it I
find different ways to keep saying the
same thing
got it new adjectives my vocab is
expanded dramatically over the last
decade different analogies I'm great
analogies my mom's dad was supposedly
grating now you she always tells me I
picked that up from him i crush
analogies you know I love that [ __ ]
being fully myself when I broke out in
2009 most of the world in the comments
on LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and on
its rim Twitter Facebook and YouTube and
definitely email and definitely my
friends in my inner circle of business
associates almost everybody told me to
stop cursing that I would never get big
if I cursed I remember that year 2009
this is way before you do 2008 76 like
early me 2009 like it was just maybe you
were there nonetheless I apologize but
like you know it just like people like
you know like way back then you know 9
the culture was a little bit different
than cursing was a little bit more like
but that's just the way I talk my mom
[ __ ] curses that's why I pick it up
from I know you're watching mom take
that you know like but she's cursed in
Russian so it took me a while to realize
she was actually cursing but you know
I'm I'm a jersey outside in the words
kind of like Jersey kid and like that's
that's how we talk and so I was
authentically me I just a consistent and
I'll always be consistent that's how you
do it Matthew and do you think just and
I've always tried to tell my my podcast
people like I'm gonna be transparent
I've shared the bad times as well in the
past year and a half and I think that I
kind of thought to myself kind of what
you're saying if I'm if I'm right is
that if I be myself maybe they'll come
around after so much if I just be
consistent it might be like oh maybe I
should try this positivity thing is that
kind of Matt Matt do you understand that
some people have
followed me literally for six years
every day and today's the day they
[ __ ] finally take my nice don't you
that's exactly the reason you have to be
consistent is you never know when
today's the day that they're ready and
you say it the way that they're ready
for people like people ask me all the
time to like hey Gary do you ever get
tired of like you know like you know
people not listening I'm like no it's
not about me I need to just be
consistent say it different ways
challenge myself creatively so that
today's the day and I say it the right
way
boom like I didn't know coronavirus was
gonna come that was gonna give me an
opportunity to our morning show every
day
mmm like somebody's gonna get affected
from yesterday somebody's gonna sell a
ton of [ __ ] in their house that's gonna
buy them those two extra months that are
gonna change of course of their life
because it sells stuff Saturday this
Saturday self sells stuff Saturday
looking hash tag you know I didn't know
that that was gonna be day I came up
with it on the spot as you probably saw
if you watched yesterday like you know
so no bro it's about it's about staying
consistent knowing today might be the
day that Karen and you know I was ready
to hear it finally okay because [ __ ] I
took brother should I talk about people
don't want to do
be patient for 15 years save money don't
buy dumb [ __ ] like people are gonna try
a lot of young people are gonna try
every other version before they come
back to me they like me because I'm
entertaining and come across cool to
them but they actually don't want to do
my [ __ ] you know me hypocritical Gary
Vee fans there are who love me but do
nothing that I talk about
yeah that's what I needed thank you got
you take baby here you do let's keep
this going to spawn by the way I'm
really enjoying everybody's taking
screenshots of this and posting it on
Twitter and and I'm retweeting their
accounts Cory waters you're in and I
just have found some of you [ __ ]
boom carry Cory waters you've just been
followed Cory I see that you're in New
Jersey I'm gonna ask you to now are you
signing up for wine text let's see what
Cory responds with
like this so like be sharing their evil
Matt Smith Jenna hey how are you I'm
well how are you good thank you thanks
for doing this I'm super grateful to be
on and super each other great were you
from from Long Island New York
so not bark yeah so I've had a side
hustle for two years now it's a clothing
brand
I basically market to people who are
underpaid that's actually the name of
the brand and on even before thank you
even before all this because by the way
I apologize for interrupting you why
that's such a brilliant brand name
everybody thinks you're underpaid yeah
exactly and that's why I came up with it
but lately I've been thinking about like
did I pick the right niche like I'm
sales have just not been good and and
are slowly losing passion for it like I
are you many are you losing so listen
let's talk about passion real quick what
do you have a sense if your passion is
money
, that's a be the the process of making
money
is it a money actual money is it be the
process of making money or is it C
having a fashion brand and being
creative which one is your passion and
by the way Jenna this is important
moment like oh all three are acceptable
there's nothing wrong with any of them
I'm just curious because it's gonna help
me help you
it's definitely C like I want well then
then then then you're using passion
because you're not getting results like
you're in the best spot cuz good news
like you picked C so if it's doing
shitty right now you know and it's a
side hustle so it's not like you know
obviously you'd love it to be your
permanent job this now gets into we need
to think about the tactics of you
building a brand and doing sales not
about the whole damn thing so that's a
good start
yeah I did
I am also multi passionate like I have a
lot of things that I want to do and
sometimes it's hard to pick like what I
want to do and you can you can play the
best you can do underpaid 85% of time
and 15% of the time do all the other
random [ __ ] because you're creative and
you're that kind of character and I find
that doing the 15 percent of other [ __ ]
empathy Boehner sports garyvee baseball
cards actually makes me go 110% on the
85% in running vaynermedia because I'm
also creative yes yeah that's the thing
like I'm so quitter enough to know that
like I don't want to die like whatever
that side hustle is like I want to go
all-in on that thing and lately I've
been thinking about like do I want to
like I've been drawing my whole life so
I've been considering like doing
something with that first going like
sword like the artists route a second it
is yes
draw something post it on Instagram film
yourself drawing it posted on tik-tok
like people have the world confused the
answer is yes to everything like yes go
that route like everybody thinks it's
like a thing oh I'm gonna make the pivot
now from fashion brand and designer to
draw like they think it's like a thing
everybody think it's like school and
life like go to school and I go to cop
and I got a it's not that it's [ __ ]
flexible this is a flexible world the
answer is yes Jenna draw some [ __ ] right
now and put it on the Internet
I know it's like that's simple but it's
like it's that simple
there is no it's just like I'm gonna
pound this into your head let's secure
the answer is yes I am a wine guy
I am an entrepreneur I am a garage
sailor I am a motivational speaker
December I like to consider it practical
optimism I am I am I am I am yes
I'm a bespoke
dealer I'm like like yeah I'm a
podcaster this is yes
everybody's a renaissance woman and man
now you don't like it's not so
structured it is that simple
well something post it I just feel like
when I take on too much from spreading
myself too thin and then I just end up
becoming like mediocre at a bunch of
things instead of becoming an expert in
one thing nope nope it's an ideology
that people use because they over judge
themselves yeah make sense yourself like
you you've got like I want to break you
out of this it's like about perspective
all this is all of this is about half
glass full half glass empty misters
talked to my dad about an idea for wine
library around wine texts and when I was
done telling him about it he went right
into the things that could go wrong and
I spent the first 18 minutes of 80
minutes I spent the first four and a
half minutes explaining it to him on
everything that was gonna go right
that's just two men with two different
perspectives yeah I mean like as far as
the brand know like you talk about like
steaming your lane and only talking
about like what you're an expert in like
I want to get people value but hold on
like I'm not I don't like I don't say
about you know it's funny this is why
it's so fun to have some time to like
break down I don't talk I don't don't
say stay in your lane of what you're an
expert in I say stay in your lane if
you're passionate about drawing
that's your [ __ ] Lane Jenna no I know
that well like as far as like my
clothing brand like the reason I'm
losing power as well as cause like I put
our content like I have a youtube
channel and like I talk about like being
underpaid I talk about my story but I
feel like there's only so much I can
only so much I can talk about my story
like I want to help people or hey or
paint I'm like I'm not a coach like I'm
not a finance expert you know what you
are you're a human you're a friend I
don't I don't know what am i I'm a human
being
you're human yeah you can you could be
doing what I'm doing right now how many
people have bought something you have a
Shopify it's like you control the direct
consumers yes the Shopify store how many
people have bought clothes roughly I
fulfilled over 200 orders and less than
two years but else have just likes I got
it that's not a lot and I get it yes you
should email all 200 of them and ask
them if they'd like to go on FaceTime
with you or live and talk about the
whole concept or what they liked about
it literally email them what's gonna
happen you million say unsubscribe [ __ ]
you like you can do it what I'm saying
is whether you do that or not you can do
anything everything can be done you want
to help people you want to talk to
people you can you don't need to be a
certified psychologist don't stay you're
a certified psychologist don't lie tell
the truth and do your a friend that
wants to talk you're a human being that
wants to talk about this subject it is
your up I don't think I'm an expert in
business I don't I think I'm a human
being
who has ideas hypothesis and opinions
ideas hypothesis and opinions if I can
and passion on my hop I'm just I hop
I'm ideas hypotheses opinions and
passion I'm the new [ __ ] IHOP
do you understand that's what I think I
yeah and I think you need to think of it
that way too
yeah I mean I could do that um I'm
essentially think about Stern in a
podcast and doing that like talking to
people or underpaid so they could share
their story Jenna took on a huge piece
of advice yeah do you have a Twitter
account
yes were you listening to the wrestling
woman that I told her to jump into
conversations I on T twenty minutes ago
and the show did you see that
interaction with the woman from Jersey
who's who does wrestling it's okay if
you didn't I'm just curious if you did
yeah it wasn't fully paying let me tell
you where I'm at I need you to go into
Twitter search the term underpaid
and jump into a conversation with every
single person read what they wrote and
then say yeah girl or like hey have you
thought about this or this is something
that's but I want to remind everybody I
Gary Vee was built on Twitter by
listening to people talking by searching
on Twitter do you know how to search
terms on Twitter yes I want you to
search under paid mm-hmm and I want you
to jump into every conversation around
people talking about underpaid there for
two hours today and then get back to me
and tell me what happened I tried that a
little bit I tried I tried selling a ton
of [ __ ] once and twice and third and it
didn't work I tried to invent a deal of
the day site for my dad for a decade but
I finally figured it out with white text
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
Jennifer yeah happy listening I had been
listening to the what you've been saying
with like sending DM I've been sending
DM so like some of my favorite rappers a
couple of them I sense I refer to so and
that's something I like I was fearing
doing for so long it's so crazy like
you're something and you're fearing a
lot of things I've spent seven minutes
with you you're in know and fear culture
and like even the framework of if I
don't focus on one thing it won't work
well is actually just a manifestation of
fear and insecurity
yeah for sure um yeah that's Jenna
listen to me
listen to me life is good you could do
this you know creative woman like let's
go for can do this just [ __ ] one year
closure you do me a favor do old Gary V
a favor for one year just close your
ears don't hear anything all the
negative feedback on the push back all
the bad sales results just make make
make make make make I don't want to hear
from any of you anymore like I've been
thinking about doing a podcast [ __ ]
do a podcast I don't want to hear from
anybody anymore saying yeah I heard you
talking about tick tock I'm debating it
[ __ ] debating [ __ ] thinking [ __ ]
pondering [ __ ] make go make yeah yeah
to get inside until their doll so
everything just doing and it's called
this it's called stop listening to other
[ __ ] people your mama I'm your dad
uncle your brother your sister
anonymous pants 47 like everybody stop
listening to them yeah that's true like
I've been I've been thinking about like
like did I lose the passion because the
shelfs doctor did I lose the passion
because like I want to do every other
things but I mean I guess is ready for
this I believe that if you do all these
other things 20% of the time you're
gonna find your passion back to the
brand or stumble on your maintenance
stumble on the thing that you actually
were meant to be which is a drawer yeah
like that's my passion like I'm actually
giving you tactical subscription a
tactical prescription I want you to
reply to 50 people on Twitter 50 today
actually that would take me an hour
might take you five hours cuz you're out
of practice or you've only done it one
time I need you to spend I want you to
apply to 50 people who have put in the
word you know underpaid then and I'm not
kidding you have an Instagram yes I'm
gonna say something very weird and I
want you to do it I want you to draw
something post it on Instagram and
literally say sorry guys but Gary B made
me do this cuz that's gonna be the
shield that will let you do this I'm
selling the strong for 80 bucks see what
happens okay Mina Jetta thank you thank
you update me on what happened okay
Twitter gonna retweet some more people
doing screen turns help help Padgett you
like that let's do that why would PR I
love that showing you hi yeah we what's
good what's good bro Nico Nicole that's
without a lot yeah
the serious day so well I'm so so quick
palm to talk to you first off I just
want to say I'm super grateful for you
in my life cause like I've been grinding
through your content eight months
through I knew from before it was just
that these eight months have like
transformed me and I got super fond that
I'm so so grateful so thank you for that
for the bottom who are you from I'm from
India but I'm standing here in Canada
and well universities just sort of a
backup so to come to my point so I have
like two questions one I want to be a
musician so I'm really passionate about
music so I obviously heard you talking
about tick tock and I start a tick tock
I don't have I have over 200 videos at
this point but it's not working out for
me in terms of like the audience
watching cuz I'm still I get thirty five
followers at this point so on because
you know you're not good at it right now
right which is good okay that's fine but
what you need to learn from this point
you can't have 200 videos and have 35
followers you needed to realize
somewhere along the line that you have
to do something completely different
because nobody likes what the [ __ ]
you're doing right and that's okay yeah
you know you know my my mindset I think
it's [ __ ] awesome that you have 200
videos and only $35 like you might be
the worst tick-tock er in the world and
I think that's amazing yeah
yeah I think that's a good thing yeah
you know yeah what I would do right now
because I would your next five tic TOCs
you have to do something completely
uncomfortable completely different
completely the if you don't dance you do
a ridiculous bad dance with one of the
trending dancers you look at the
trending hashtags and you come up with
something instead of doing what you what
have you been mainly putting up there um
all like singing video so like the other
day there was this guy I'm pretty sure
you watched him so it's about I'm voting
the house um in the house board so I
took this song and I made a melody for
it and then I posted on ticked off and
I'm like that yeah and then like one
person commented and she was like oh
this should be more popular but again
like it got a bit of traction and then
it was like that can I give you a huge
okay I'm gonna give you recipe today
today
I want you to go - tick-tock and I want
you to leave a comment on 100 100
different posts got it yep
watch watch it and write a reply
I believe that three of your replies
could go viral and that that will double
your audience in one day hit me up on
Twitter tomorrow and tell me what
happened sure will do okay number two
second question and my second question
was so I obviously got I watched since I
watched a lot of youth content I got
into like flipping and sports cards and
stuff like that and honestly I'm like a
guy who loves trying out stuff and like
seeing it work for me and like in so
it's been like three months since I
started flipping and stuff like that
I've been flipping stuff I'm like I I'm
doing with sports cars and it's been
pretty good but I feel like I'm just
confused whether like that's my thing as
a lot of my time goes into like doing
that because you're sourcing stuff and
then coming back like an international
student I don't have like a car or
anything so I'm obviously so new to the
city itself what about buying stuff on
the internet having it shipped to you
and then reef lipping it so that you
don't so you can maximize your arbitrage
of time like you mean like sourcing from
Alibaba and stuff like that yeah we're
sourcing from just sourcing from the
internet I mean I buy cards on eBay have
been delivered and then repost them on
eBay because I was right that the player
was gonna be better than when I bought
him
yeah I mean I started doing that but
like my question was that I don't know
if like I enjoy it as much as I could do
it I can tell you right now I already
know that you don't right I can just
like you should not be flipping I'm glad
you gave it you know you're crushing it
you know how I talk about tasting things
you're very good at it it comes natural
to you news alert just like 200 videos I
only got 35 followers you need to change
it up three months and the level you're
taught your voice went down when you
started talking you don't like it as
much right and remember when I talked
about [ __ ] Gary Vee [ __ ] anybody else bu
it's clearly not for you but I'm pumped
that you tried it because it might have
been the life changer we now too
to move on to the next thing I mean
honestly I was coming in for or yes or
maybe you need to flip something else
maybe flipping sports cards not fun but
going to thrift stores and flipping
fashion is fun or maybe go in Alibaba
and buying you know I'm white mug for
three bucks and then selling it for 11
bucks on on Etsy is exciting for you so
maybe it's what you're flipping right
sure I mean I honestly got into flipping
and then I started looking at from a
money angle because I'm obviously like
an international student course and you
know and like my parents are paying for
my tuition and I owe it to them to
obviously give it back right yeah but in
the process like you always talk about
pursuing happiness and passion and
that's gonna lead you to earn more money
not not not not necessarily more money
happier money right yeah sorry you know
to me a hundred twelve thousand dollars
a year take-home selling glasses because
that was what it ended up being is much
better than 400 thousand dollars being
an engineer because that's where your
grandma wanted you - yeah I do I believe
that I don't know what else to say I
mean I've lived like I'm old at this
point it's very obvious to me like if
it's just very odd it's a [ __ ] black
and white yeah and every [ __ ] person
that tells me like [ __ ] you like I'd
rather have like I'm like just cuz you
don't know because you know because you
don't have $400,000 that's what you
think [ __ ] true a harm % yeah
yes the process not more not more you
know that's an important part and this
I'm using tea with Gary B to create more
clarification because when people hear
more when they don't make more after
four years like [ __ ] Gary I'm like
that you love selling [ __ ]
pumpkins yeah yeah I do I'm like you
want yeah right so yeah I just got
confused within that cuz like I'm like
trying to help my parents right in the
process of like real quick Nicole you
have your whole life to pay your parents
back yeah you're not in the position
right now to really crush it do you
understand
patience my man yeah
gotcha cool I'm gonna run come to you
soon man all right thanks man thank you
all right back to Twitter by the way
here's something I will follow every
person that tells me that they just
signed up the wine text on Twitter if
you sign up to wine text calm right now
not every state can be shipped - but if
you do and you tweet me right now
and you say just cite I gave you just
sign up with wine text and show me the
confirmation screen so shoot that
because I'm not [ __ ] trusting you I
will follow you on twitter join us hello
hi what's your name Melinda malinka how
are you my family for 63 years if I
actually in with the business and really
deeply connected to it and our brand is
who we are which is that we love people
we love serving my family came from
Yugoslavia and really America's been so
good to us
so now coronavirus is here and we're
doing carryout and me we're known for
being old-school and so I've been using
technology Instagram Facebook I'm not
that old but it hasn't come that
naturally to me but I have started to do
more of it with with sort of your
promptings and advice and I want to know
in these let's say 18 months door to
door the coronavirus sort of keeps us
here what can I do to learn some from
this help my business do things that I
wouldn't normally do because I wouldn't
have the time because we're so hands-on
and sort of not intimidated by it are
you is there any way that we can film
whoever it is whether it's you whether
it's another family member whether it's
a chef is there any way that we can film
the making of every dish you sell from
home or one person goes to the
restaurant is there any way we can do
that well it's
interesting as were known for all of our
recipes being family secret so the old
road that's cool you can get a recipe is
by providing a male heir to our throne
otherwise otherwise we don't share
that's amazing I should listen people
buy from people so where I was going
with the recipe and now maybe we go a
different route how many family members
are in the business so my mother my
brother and I are there everyday I'll
tell you the number one thing that I
would do I would try to put out on
Instagram Facebook YouTube tick tock all
of them you have to sign up for all of
them and I know you get it and you're on
two of them now and I get it's not
natural I believe in this so much I
think you need to do story time I mean
your mom probably has [ __ ] some real
crazy [ __ ] you guys have a ton of crazy
[ __ ] cuz you're like living above the
restaurant I think you need to put out
100 videos of different stories about
the restaurant and post them locally I
genuinely believe that it will lead to
an increase in take out during now and
it will be build even more brand do you
know how much good business things that
good life things happen to me because
people know I was born in Belarus
because they know I sold lemonade as a
kid because they know I sold baseball
cards stories the Bible movies it's all
about stories and I think while we're
all confined right now everybody needs
to go into hardcore story time you have
a real blessing you guys have real
[ __ ] stories I literally think you
take a [ __ ] phone first of all you'll
be happy that you recorded your mom
telling 25 stories one day anyway you
know what I mean I think it's story time
for you I mean it 100 stories from the
five of you from the six of you and
posted on every platform and you'll
learn how to post it differently on
tik-tok than on youtube like this
your time to learn it is learning and
good news you know what doesn't come
natural to me working from home and Here
I am on the fourth day and I'm [ __ ]
liking it are you really yeah I'm
shocked so maybe you'll really like
making tic TOCs you just don't know
until you do it
storytime please do me a huge favor
today's been a big day on tea for Gary
Vee about action please record two
stories today thank you soon everybody
it's one of those stories from your mom
will go viral I'm telling you right now
it will ya for screaming at me maybe
[Music]
keep this going I didn't see I need a
plan this thing if you just another one
convinced lined up carry that's true
Peralta follow you that and Tanner's in
the building
Tanner what's good right I'm doing well
how are you Gary I am doing really well
man like I really I really feel like
there's something here with a storm at
right
I've watched every day and it's
definitely a value yeah what's your
biggest observation so far um honestly
you know with your askgaryvee shows like
that you know it feels a little similar
to that but you're going even deeper it
doesn't feel as rushed because I'm not
rushed right as much to your point yeah
right and it's able to shoot it anyway
what's up man yeah so I'll get right to
it so I grew up you know just to tell
them my truth I grew up very well-off my
dad came from very little he worked on
the family farm and and then he started
his own client service business was very
successful and you know so I grew up
very comfortable my mom parented me you
know perfectly as you say a lot you know
I agree you know with with my how I was
parented but he unfortunately suddenly
passed away at 45 and I was seven at the
time I was I'm so sorry yeah I
appreciate it but basically from that
moment forward I kind of went into a
cocoon just like full insular and into
my head and I really didn't come out
till after college and so fast-forward
to like how this is relevant kind of one
of my question is I've been a freelance
web designer and developer for about
five years now and the problem is I
fully believe that I self-sabotage
myself and I think it's connected to
what had happened because I actually
think you're about to hear a bomb I
think I self-sabotage myself to like I
limit my financial upside cuz I think
for me I think I just love the game so
much and I almost don't want to get
there like I'm like I'm like
inappropriately low in love with the
story and the process and like you know
kind of want to pull it out in the 12th
round you know like if I can buy the
Jets the way I want it's almost like the
Jets announced in three years they're
gonna sell it I'm nowhere close
and then I [ __ ]
make it happen why do you think when you
say you self-sabotage hey what do you
mean and why do you think you do it well
yeah so like how I do it is basically
through undercharging okay
like drastically and I don't know you
know when I went into dealing with
everything I really became a hundred
percent self-reliant and you know but I
turned something into I turned that
terrible negative situation into a
positive you know I started
weightlifting you know I gotta mentally
very very strong and it's funny my
mother Hartman's burnick my friend
Harmons critic took me in 2001 we went
to Italy on a wine trip for business and
one late night in Italy like 2:00 a.m.
he looked at me because he knows how
close I am to my dad and they were he
was talking about I'm trying to remember
story probably I think his dad had
passed recently and he said you don't
really become a man until your dad
passes and I can't believe I'm it's 20
years later I'm bringing up that one
sentence I think about it a lot I very
much think of myself as a man but I do
think about it I'm very grateful and I'd
like I can only become a man when I'm
100 because that means my dad would be a
hundred twenty but I I understand what
you're saying about that especially
somebody who had an incredibly great
gifted situation so you know that level
of a that comfort that person I was
taking care of [ __ ] gift goes away and
you kind of go inside yourself so but I
still don't fully understand why the
undercharging is connected to
self-reliance or things that nature I
actually think some people are just
naturally scared to ask for more money
like just literally and the way to
actually break that is to literally no
different like kissing a girl riding a
bike having sex for the first time
swimming it's literally just the action
of asking and in today's digital world
where you can just email them
potentially and text them like hey I'm
350 an hour instead of 175 I actually
think this is a very easy I've helped a
lot of people break this feeling I just
forced them even one of my friends
literally typed it asking for $100 more
now and at work then it kind of changed
his trajectory some consider yeah I mean
I definitely think fear is definitely a
part of that but more so I would say you
know I like things that are hard I don't
like it when it's easy and I also I
don't feel like I'm not materialistic
whatsoever I kind of went in a complete
opposite direction after all that she's
like what is all this [ __ ] all this ship
doesn't mean [ __ ] right you know I tell
myself I don't need the extra money you
know I'm saying so so so I know
something else are we okay with that
because I'm okay with self sabotaging
myself yeah I probably do it to a point
where I you know have trouble paying
bills
well that's how it might be a little
that's a problem yeah so this here we
are we watch this over and over you know
this will repost and you can will Dustin
let's chop this and email it to Tanner
ready I got you Pam okay ready
tanner what's up its Gary D charge more
money this time
cool that's gonna be a little clip save
it on your phone and just literally ask
for more money every time yeah I don't
know what to say bro it's actually that
simple yeah yeah and I gotta tell myself
like you know you can try it and if you
think it's gonna be so terrible then
we'll see how you feel oh you got to do
it so I don't know when you had that
call with that kid the other day you
know in the electrician business that
really really if he's watching this
cherish those moments man because you
know you may not have them forever
wow that was one of the few moments in
the last 15 years of being on the
internet that I actually almost cried
yeah it was a big one
I agree anyway and I really wish you
well brother honestly like it's a it's
this is an easy one man honestly it's an
easy one it's a hard one right it's like
it's it's like it's like anything again
swimming was I was scared shitless
kissing girls scared like like it but it
is easy it was just jumping into the
water it was just kissing the girl and I
think you just need to charge more money
I appreciate you so much thank you for
everything that 22nd
keep it moving keep it moving
seahorses Sundra hey what's going on
Gary
life is good bro what's going on look an
answer from so my question not to give
too much backstory or anything like that
but it's just more of like so I'm
starting to stream a lot more because I
found like obviously I have a passion
for video games right that's what I grew
up doing so I love doing a lot and but
not so much more lately because I've
been consuming a lot of your content so
I've been doing other things outside of
my life too you know uplift myself
become more positive be a harder and
better worker but uh what I wanted to
know is is how you or what's your
viewpoint on and providing free content
with value when other people in the same
area like let's say to play the same
video game as me or providing that same
kind of content but in more depth or
they're able to provide a little more
value for free uh you can only do what
you can do just learn and dive in deeper
yeah like Voges better at it than you
like what are you gonna do about it like
like like harder yeah and by the way
maybe it's more about you know maybe he
might be better at showing the skill set
but you might be more entertaining or
you might be more vulnerable and talk
about [ __ ] or you might talk about goaty
culture in a way that he can't you know
like this is about making it about you
like look there's people there's
probably nothing I talked about that
there isn't somebody who talks about
that specific thing quote unquote better
but the cat is in the mix that's the
cat's name it's Li Zi Zi she was yeah
she woke up because the girl or boy Z
didn't like hit the line Alondra girl
got it so you know
he knows the good stuffs coming right
now so like honestly it's just about
being you you know like you're you're
getting caught up that somebody's doing
yeah can you hear me all right doesn't
take them off unfortunately but I'll
give the answer doesn't look we could
move on dust Alejandra I'm sorry but
here's I'm that's someone hold on a
second
no race Alejandra I'll finish my answer
to you and then we gave somebody else on
here somebody else being better at
something we'll always be the case in
every situation in perpetuity there are
very few people that are literally
actually the best in the world at
something and so oh there you are so
then getting you know getting into it
you will never be the best in the world
and anything so getting comfortable with
that and still doing it because you can
still be the 17th best or the 17,000
best but it's free so you know like
you're in a great spot don't like
honestly new and you're doing what
everybody else does everybody else is
just watching everybody else like I I'm
bro and I tell you that I don't know
anything that might be agencies that
compete with Boehner the other business
gurus I mean people who is like oh you
know Rick Thompson and I'm like I don't
know I mean I've heard the name of
course yeah but like I don't know what
anybody's [ __ ] doing that's what
makes me happy let's move cuz he's
rapping let's move it you know great
hearing something like that from you
thank you baby that's me but he's
chopping I got you so this next person
is Elijah Kim I think you talked to him
yesterday
the guitarist for rowdy rich haha it's
good it's good it's Chopin Hey
so I mainly wanted to come on here and
say cuz I took your advice I know you
had that one video where you're talking
about like hey if things aren't working
out like move back home if you have that
option and kind of readjust cuz I was
working like full time last year I was
working for a candidate's company I'm
even smoke
and just like super unfulfilled I'm 26
now right and that feeling only like got
worse as I got older and you're like
it's because I was kind of working
against that perpetual clock and so I I
mean you know how much I hate that
[ __ ] clock if I can suck it if I can
[ __ ] break everybody's clock of like
what they're supposed to do at 25 30 40
50 60 bro
I hate that [ __ ] clock like nobody
yeah yeah and I don't even know if it
was like self imposed but like I just
know that I was at home in my Clermont
which is like a super slow suburban area
and like Southern California I'm just
like chillin on like the floor up like
my parents house I'm just like thinking
like like I cuz I basically dedicated my
life to like trying to make something
happen with music right and so I'm like
putting everything I can into like
making my guitar sound great all this
stuff I'm just like praying super hard
and then like after like six months of
being back home like I met my friend
his name's keifa and he like hooking me
up and left sudden I'm one two or three
rich and like within the blink of an eye
like you know I'm like kind of like two
other people they're kind of viewings
like oh my god like that's so crazy like
I never knew you do this like that and
so it was just kind of crazy like for
like basically like two overnight to
like kind of have some sort of something
happened with like music so I just want
to say you know it just makes me so
happy I don't know if you've been
noticing cuz I posted a bunch of rowdy
stuff on social I'm just so about his
sound and [ __ ] with him so heavy and
she's hearing the story but just think
about the world actually works it's just
so [ __ ] fresh you know yeah you know
what's crazy is that um I like I talked
to Kiefer like the day after the album
came out and so he's like he you must
ma'am yeah I was like not really he's
like to listen to ya so I listened to it
we hit rehearsals and then the record
went number one at the box I went number
one while we were like rehearsing for
tour so it's like it wasn't even that
big of a deal like everything was sold
out but it's like it was like like the
like the venue spike
could have been bigger just because like
do like explode he's like 11 weeks at
number one now you know or 11 inclusive
yeah so it's just like it was just like
so crazy I just be on tour and all of a
sudden like that records just like
caught fire we're just like do you
listen when I talk about a lot about
this one sentence doing the right things
always the right thing for you the right
thing at that time was taking a step
back and getting into that place if you
don't move in with your parents
this never happens the end yeah yeah
yeah so currently I'm like hearing that
like so you know everything's obviously
gone cancel with like her own virus or
anything like that or at least postponed
yes um I'm like kind of like floating
around I'm like staying at my cousin's
house right now what yeah oh yeah you
need to live on Instagram live in
tik-tok live and make tic TOCs all day
yeah yeah you need to make four tic TOCs
a day if I [ __ ] complete guitar I'd
be [ __ ] the biggest person in the
world with tic toc right now yeah you
need to cut today yeah 26 sounded yeah
it was rough but you know it worked
go make four tic TOCs a day it will work
yeah is it do you is it just like
showcasing you want to cast it but what
I think you should do is look at the
trends both trending dances and trending
topics and then incorporate that with
your guitar into however you think about
it yeah right so I'm going to look right
now keeping example so like for example
right now on tic toc this you know
you're going to discover and you kind of
look at what's there right what's
trending right now cats cats of
tick-tock is your cousin had a cat yeah
I know but maybe I could relax
you know like play-by-play right
distance dance right so distance dance
is exploding
like what like if you like right now
with the first scene it took us like no
distance dance is blowing up now let me
get hard behind it and just like [ __ ]
RIF something mean that could be the one
to choose your career game cuz Beyonce
might see it because she's bored right
now looking at tick-tock and boom bro
it's about making yeah
online classes trending happy at home
right at happy at home trend somebody's
the first one that's trending is
somebody playing the [ __ ] piano tell
me how that's different than playing the
[ __ ] guitar [ __ ] make [ __ ] bro
that's a good point for tick-tocks a day
Elijah I [ __ ] you listen to something
once before and already change your life
you do this one tick tocks made for
music content bro you're [ __ ] sitting
at home bored
you jerk off all day like [ __ ] me
guitar [ __ ] I'm gonna do that for sure I
believe you
I believe you all right brother talk you
soon thank you so much Gary you got it
Gary B hope everybody's enjoying heading
into the second hour excited about this
I have all sorts of tea companies by the
way talk about like meta like have
nothing but tea companies DMing me and
hitting me up on email offering
sponsorship deals to drink their tea on
TV Gary Vee something that came up three
days ago so like it all can happen and
you're like all but you're Gary Vee but
ya [ __ ] cried it for a decade to put
myself in that [ __ ] spot so I got a
couple questions for you the first one
will give me a little bit of background
I just finished school um was an 1800
hour course become a mechanic got
straight A's that's possible attendance
I could have I need a career I'm 32
I've been sober now for just under four
years April 3rd and you know four years
thank you
Fanny mom I'm thinking that he likes now
on it's a bang I mean I need a little
bit more caffeine than early in the
morning I'm in Florida so that hour
behind you but on it the question is is
um for a very very long time I said
press myself um through do drugs and
alcohol I listen to the music that other
people listen to do because they said
that was the music I needed to be
listening to I watched the things on TV
that other people we're watching because
they said that was the best show on so
for so long I suppressed who I really
was after loss now now that the the the
the the cloud is gone and the cobwebs
have been cleared
I find myself sitting walking around
what should I be liking is it okay to
like this is it okay - yes so interest
in this yes is there a Michael who's in
charge right into your point you valued
other people more than yourself so who
was in charge in high school was whoever
the coolest kid was that you know who
was in charge of girl who was in charge
missed homie like your whole life to
your point up until 28/29 was was you
know was was about somebody else being
in charge well you now that things are
clear or not the answer is it okay is
yes to everything because you get to be
the judge in the jury broke 90% of my
real business friends made fun of me for
making garage sale videos the first time
I did it couple years ago right the good
news was they weren't in charge of said
go [ __ ] yourself right right the answer
is of course if you're a nerd then be a
nerd because nerds are cool now if you
love cooking good if you love ballet for
some weird reason mother right right of
course the answer is yes who you playing
for besides yourself you were playing
for everybody else's affirmation you
needed outside affirmation that's weak
and that's why you got [ __ ] up but now
and what I talk about is inside
affirmation you just you that's why I
was talking about that Drago [ __ ] from
Rocky or why they be so hard he's like
I'll say it again because I love to
reenact it at the end of that movie when
he loses he's like [ __ ] I
fought for me I was in the ring I wasn't
fighting Russia versus America this was
for fee for [ __ ] me and like that's
where you got to convert like it's all
you now no more
dad uncle best friends in pass pretty
girl the year like no you are you and
now I have I have one more question so
in the process of me getting back to you
know where where I'm at now I've had to
I had to write down a lot of what you
know of some of my baggage and cleared
up a little bit and you know some of the
resentment and and really process
supposed to be able to let it go
a big thing was a list of fears yeah and
I realized that you know getting
completely honest with myself that that
one of my fears was not only the fear of
failure but fear success for years I've
set the bar extremely low you know and
the expectation of anybody else where
you just lost on me because hey we know
he can't do it so why even expect
anything out of them that way there was
no letdown I was already realized out
you know what I'm saying
so now that I know so now that I know
that you know I can get good grades and
I can get straight A's and like you know
I just you know got a job that I you
know I've been working towards and you
know it's my first job out of drug
addiction after a decade is makes more
than what my mom's made and my mom's
been at her job for 30 plus years and so
it's like man I have I have the real
opportunity to [ __ ] this up you know
like King with him what if I'm not
competent what if when am I go in there
and or straight A's don't mean [ __ ] to
practical application you sure
absolutely
what what you're going down the path of
is where you been and this is why we got
to fight it what would happen then you
want a good [ __ ] mechanic 1800 hours
towards being you're worried about
judgment bro
like 1800 hours I don't you people spend
a few hundred hours watching Netflix
tour in Corona 1800 hours ain't [ __ ] and
number two what somebody's would be like
oh I know what you're worried about
they're like she [ __ ] knew it had a
[ __ ] good he was good for 18 months
but he saw once a loser always worried
about other people's opinions [ __ ] them
bro I know no no I really no no this
isn't one of those I'm like you know
like it's let's play for a second here
like what like what like you're gonna
have to understand rewire it I mean you
let me rephrase you understand better
than 99% of the people here you've spent
the last four years rewiring like I
admire you so much do you know how hard
it is to do being drug addiction for a
decade and actually get out most don't
right there's nothing you'll ever
accomplish professionally that I'll
admire more than your ability to get out
a pretty one I actually mean it too bro
I don't like throwing admiration around
I'm a little bit weird that way like you
know why are you man you already won who
gives a [ __ ] if you're a shitty mechanic
seriously I don't know right like it's
time that you [ __ ] stop worrying
about other people's opinions I don't
give a [ __ ] one listen you know I don't
know how long you've been following my
con what did you find my content prob
about two and a half three years ago you
know those little bites about you know
[ __ ] expectation you know those kind of
this is what I listen I play the rubber
scheme I don't give a [ __ ] that people
think I'm a genius or they think I'm the
best or I'm gonna buy the jacks I can't
hear them I'm asking you to cut out the
booze the booing I cut out the cheering
you know why cuz he's a kid I cut out
the booing I didn't give a [ __ ] that mr.
riddle thought I was gonna be a loser I
knew I wasn't going to be and more
importantly if I was gonna be mr.
riddles and
user and everybody's a loser maybe I'm a
[ __ ] nobody's life has anything to do
with mine and that's that you're you're
still in your the reason you're in
self-doubt or anxiety of like does
school map to skills here will I keep
flourishing what if I get fired is
because you still actually then care
what somebody's gonna say about it
and until you thought the way you got
off the [ __ ] [ __ ] chemicals you
need to spend every day reinforcing when
when I [ __ ] up here when I quit when I
get fired and everybody's got something
to say I don't care I'm gonna start a
pizza shop I'm gonna work in a pizza
store I'm gonna ride a bike I mean it
doesn't [ __ ] matter thank you I
appreciate it really I did it means a
lot to me man thanks do you understand
yeah yeah no I mean I know a lot of
things are easier said than done
for a long time I had help from people
so I didn't fall completely under the
surface and the reasons why I am still
alive so I I kind of feel like I not so
much oh them right oh hey you do owe
them that you owe them by being happy
not by making money or being a mechanic
or being professionally successful right
I just want to show them that they're
they're happy they didn't waste no their
investment on they're happy
what do you think your mom your aunt or
your uncle your destiny board give them
a shout-out who are the core people my
my mom my fiancee and that's my brother
my older brother and that's that about
it let me promise you something unreal
unreal you paying them back isn't in the
form of you holding a steady job it's
you being a happy human being and they
say that do you need a dick right stop
[ __ ]
[ __ ] into something it's not bro I
promise you those to me just are [ __ ]
grateful you're alive they don't give a
[ __ ] if you're making 110 a year so just
go be happy thanks man I appreciate it
you're the man thanks you are Michael
I'm really really impressed by you man
that's a real hard battle I'm real
impressed
thank you I'm man I love you man really
you're exactly what I need when I need
it all the time
you're so consistent and again I mean
you're you you really get me going you
get me going through hard times a lot of
the time and I appreciate that that an
outside influence that's not padding you
know you kind of tell me what I need to
hear you tell me you know what I have to
hear and then I greatly appreciate that
I appreciate Michael thank you bro all
right yep
take care you just kind of what's good
for I've been following your content for
about two issues and I really really
love what not only what you say but how
you say it and it really resonates with
me because I'm all about you know
leaning in and trying to figure out how
people are saying and what they're what
the intent behind what they're saying is
so I really resonate with what you say
how you say it so first of all love
thank you so I want to pick your brain
about something all right so you always
talk about loving the process behind
what you do so yeah so my question is in
your experience are are there any
elements to the process that you find
difficult to love right I figured
because because that's not the process
again people just want the
good points in the process right exactly
exactly
rather Dakota people don't love the dirt
the way I love it
mm-hmm right I reckon love adversity and
[ __ ] you know toughness pain and
estimation I got chips on shoulders bro
you're right I understand yeah no of
course I don't find it difficult you
know why you believe in me you you tell
me what you and Michael just told me all
that love and compassion admiration
[ __ ] that's intoxicating I love it
next person comes on and says you
[ __ ] suck Gary Vee you ain't buying
[ __ ] [ __ ] you suck [ __ ] you
snake oil salesman you never buying the
Jets
I [ __ ] love that war right yeah
totally you know when I have a great
meeting where I'd love to sell and I'm
selling Boehner and we close a two
million dollar deal and I'm in my
element loved he comes in and says the
[ __ ] roof is leaking in Chattanooga
are we had a flood in Li si or we have
somebody with the corona buy like love
that too even more more time general
right leader yeah no the process is both
everybody rides on tripping everybody
loved entrepreneurship the last 10 years
until today that's true right like wait
a minute
mm-hmm right wait a minute I shouldn't
let that job mmm right hindsight
everybody loves [ __ ] their dreams
exactly exactly like this right 100%
yeah so I guess the where that question
comes from is you know I'm in right now
I'm studying music and sometimes there's
parts about it that I'm like you know
ooh yeah exactly and you know what helps
exactly yeah
that's what I've been trying to like
you've been you've been one of the big
you know voices on the social media or
whatever that I that I'm that I'm taken
from the same patience patience patience
and
that has helped me so much because that
makes me so happy
it helped me to like everything's old
school was for me from fourth grade on
eight years a [ __ ] pain punished four
times a year you know like you know
right it was all uh you know mm-hmm
right right so uh and I just I just
sometimes I just stick I take psyche
your words they get in there just so you
know that and I know you know that
you're you're doing it right but for me
so you're hearing it from me it's in
there because I just I just turned 25
and I'm like man exactly and like I got
all this time in the world to like
located the the bad parts of the process
are the most important parts of the
process right exactly
totally [ __ ] what's good Jeremiah
let me get you up from you in a second
time today how are you you regular good
man where you from I'm from I live in
Boston right now where'd you grow up
uh upstate New York western New York
Geneseo you're Bills fan absolutely
I'm so excited for next year you should
be the most optimistic potential you've
had ever instincts know so so a couple
of years ago I switched up my content
strategy my personal strategies I'm a
musician I try to do a bunch of things
online to get my music heard so I
started making videos about cowboy boots
and playing songs at the end of the
videos to sort of share the fact that I
didn't music it did really well I went
from 80 subscribers to now almost 8000
in 2000 two years
and it's growing really fast I have like
brand deals I'm doing giveaways on my
YouTube like every month Jeremiah
besides YouTube where do you put out
content to drive outside of YouTube
where do you put out content to drive
awareness to your YouTube Twitter
Facebook I have a Facebook boot group as
well
smart with 1,500 members love Instagram
I've been dabbling with tik-tok but I
haven't quite hit it yet so I guess just
spend more time in there
how often are you posting on tik-tok
I've only done like four in the past few
months Oh bro Jeremiah do me a favor let
the serendipity of this moment force you
to make to make to a day will do your
cowboy boots is such a good luck dude
you're gonna win I'm your one tick-tock
dude you're gonna you're gonna love me
so much in seven weeks I already love
you I've like I haven't probably since
2011 more thank you bro what can I
answer for you
so with all the subscribers that I have
I've been trying to increase the
sponsorships on my channel and you are
always saying that influencers don't
know how to price themselves but you've
never actually said how influencers
should price themselves so that's my
question so what I talk about there is
they don't know how to price themselves
because they guess yeah through their
management or themselves so sometimes
somebody wants $7000 so wine text right
you can tell them pretty obsessed about
it
we're starting to do an influencer
campaign and some people want $3,000 to
post and we've got them kind of with
their engagement and their numbers price
that you know 500 bucks right and how do
we do that we look at what we could buy
on Instagram zantron
how much a CPM cost per thousand
impressions and if we know that we can
pay eight bucks for wine leathers well
then that's kind of like how we see it
and if then we're getting 20,000
questions we do eight times you know 20
you know for that person and you just do
the math other people want a hundred
bucks and we've got them math down at
4,000 so yeah people like the way you
understand if somebody's gonna do a
sponsorship on your channel there's the
ability for that same
to run ads on pre-roll YouTube's against
people that searched boots on Google
against an each panel now your
endorsement has a value so it's not just
even math your cosine has real value so
though but for you on your side that's
not your problem you need to price as
high as possible and when they say no
you're more than welcome to lower the
price okay because your endorsement is a
is a kind of non tangible nothing like
for example I don't do brand deals I've
done one thing in my career where I was
a partner with k-swiss but I don't do
brand deals but companies have come to
me and have offered me real real money
you know like on my podcast
you know hefty six figures just to be
like everybody askgaryvee or you know
hey everybody the podcast is brought to
you by let me give you a company like it
but not it brought to you by salesforce
salesforce a great solution for all
businesses all right let's get into a
Jeremias here today right just to do
that I've been offered mid six figures
right and I've said no because really
honestly if I'm gonna do that a lot of
my audience know he's never done that
before that's a big cosign let me look
at it
why were they able to get him to do that
and very honestly if I'm gonna do that I
want millions of dollars to even
consider it
that's it because but you can't put a
tangible value on my cosign just based
on how many subscribers or listeners or
Watchers of this team again idea so
there's there's that's always where the
gray sits so is it an outreach game
because the cowboy boot industry is just
really traditional I'm sure they're not
yes doing the pre-roll yes well yeah
there's an outreach game you should
email every single D company during
coronavirus you've got time I'm email
every one of them and set and play with
different titles have you seen my videos
on YouTube opportunity for you that's
one title dear Big Town YouTube social
media collaboration and opportunity read
inside like just play play play play and
you think that there is more of an
opportunity to get to them now because
I've done all that several times in the
yesterday yes and maybe you wrote shitty
and maybe about right and tell me the
truth Jeremiah how many times how many
people have you emailed tell the truth I
don't even know like it's it's a every
every single Boot Company that there is
and then I also email everybody who puts
ads love my Instagram on Facebook and I
did that like at least three times let
me tell you another story remember you
and your content wasn't doing well and
then you switched it up and you did
boots and it worked yes your copy on the
email title and the pitch is [ __ ] okay
good you're gonna email every one of
them and try different tactics you
really selling me not selling enough you
didn't make it bigger about a social
media campaign have you hear something a
little super work look at the boot
company then go to their Instagram
YouTube and Twitter and then write was
bored during the coronavirus I audited
all your social media then you give them
your opinion on their YouTube Twitter
and Instagram and then and then nothing
else nothing else they'll just see your
signature and then your URL to your
YouTube channel who the [ __ ] is this and
this is smart they're gonna reply to you
minimally saying thank you because he
spent 30 minutes of time think about
smart what I just told you yeah that's
great perfect thank you so much Gary I
appreciate it
have a great day Jane I think she wants
to do the one piece with more concepts
guys today is an action day you know I
notice a lot of you tweeting about it
today's today's the [ __ ] action today
big shout out to Brandon Z just said on
the coolest [ __ ] in the world
they're live please send me up on
Twitter a lot of you have to engage with
me way more in Twitter but today's an
action there I've given a lot of tactics
a lot of realized [ __ ] a lot of stuff
you should be doing so please do after
this we're gonna get off in a half an
hour and I want you to [ __ ] do okay
we just keep on you make some shoutouts
to people on Twitter
pies at Josh Ali which good JB JB JB J
this person actually did shave his head
- who didn't sit yeah I did see one
takes that arm set up with my dad have
[Music]
patience is the key name that is what's
going on Destin give me some shitty uh
transitions here well we're supposed to
have with two or three people in the
[ __ ] yeah I'm trying to connect I
think when you have that problem you
gotta throw actually right Hayley your
film you good morning how are you where
you from I'm from Miami Florida good
cookin so I'm a photographer I've been
doing this for about a year
professionally and I'm doing my own
court folio hiring models
I am DMing people but the DMing is not
really going anywhere for me are you
spamming them kind of yeah I even got
muted by one of my favorite people you
like I said to the last guy you have to
bring people value I try Ally I go with
people I know I need like you like I
even with you a couple days ago telling
you that I could be your photographer
and I could do events I'm product
photography and all of this and I'm
doing that but are you entering your
treachery yes I do a lot of you are you
starting the sentence with like I love
what you do I'd like to do a free photo
shoot with you no strings attached is
that what you're writing
yeah so then I think let's convert it
from DMS if you're not getting the
cadence there let's start leaving
comments I started doing
so on Twitter mostly students to people
that stood on Instagram saying hey rowdy
rich love your stuff
whenever you're Miami I'd love to do
some free photography for you
you know because then some other people
may see it in the comments and maybe
it's not rowdy rich but you might be
able to get somebody else
okay okay I'll start doing that too um
so I'm kind of stuck right now with
photography other than the DM thing I'm
not really sure what to do next
um I already have a good posting on
Pinterest Pinterest
no not Pinterest I'm posting on
Instagram links and Linkedin I've been
doing a lot maybe because I just got
into it it's really Bobby um so I just
found it about three or four days ago
and I just been like spamming my whole
main thing I think um I think first you
have to post everywhere and second you
have to have strategy to what you're
posting it's not just posting for the
sake of posting for example if you post
on LinkedIn hey guys bored with Corona
like everybody else doing a livestream
to teach photographers how to be better
at the Tata feed if you're interested
email me here that's gonna get seven
people to reply livestream okay you
gotta bring value right and now you can
come in a free photo shoot but when
you're super famous I mean I get offered
free photography four thousand hugs a
day okay right but but but you reaching
out to my sister and also her free
photography might matter you know what
it means like all these different games
you're bringing value to people by doing
live-streaming teaching them how to do
photography so flip on it which that may
lead to that person telling their dad
that you taught them and their dad has a
business that then asks you to do
photography like it's all about
innovation ideas pinche this is a real
place that I think you can find so pay
there so you will learn that pop one I
think you should start a photography
he's art of Miami Pathan Rafi group
Facebook group immediately very high on
Facebook roots I think there's huge
opportunity there and I like narrow I
like the Miami photography great right
okay
like some ideas okay sounds good Gary
thank you I just wanted to tell you one
more thing um please my boyfriend he he
he lost his cousin about a year ago and
he was really really down I couldn't
even get him out of it but I showed him
your trash talk cuz he used to do that
as a hobby so I've been showing him the
trash talk videos and he's been doing
very very well with his flipping stuff
and he has passion was happy now and I
want to thank you for doing that for him
thank you for saying that yeah it's been
very hard for us because we're both
doing something on the side and I'm with
both busy and I I i before you I
couldn't get him out of that bat hole
thank you thank you thank you so much
again you too bye bye so fun thank you
guys all for sharing these news stories
means the world to me John does not
drink wine I've had Pro okay a Chris
Barrett in the building that's good
what's going on man life is good wait
look Indiana in the woods in Kentucky
right now with this whole quarantine
stuff gonna respect respect respect
respect
well hey first thing I want to do is
shout out to all of our service workers
I know they don't get enough credit
nurses doctors grocery store clerks all
that stuff man they're putting their
self at risk
oh I know it's not a sum not really put
them on a platform but they but they
need to with all the [ __ ] that's going
on I agree Chris thank you for saying
that
yeah man hey so I'm reaching out I own a
small boutique real-estate firm in
Indiana and I live in a Division one
college town and I'm always looking to
be different I'm not I'm not into like
competing with people when it comes to
doing the exact same [ __ ] that they're
doing so I I love what I'm doing I don't
need the motivation super excited about
where my my my team is going what my
we're where my business is going but uh
I I want to be connected to the
community a little bit more to the to
the University and from what I've
researched and I researched a lot
nobody's doing what I want to do which
is can you hear me okay I give you great
I was excited about jumping in you just
said something that excites me which is
I really get worried that people think
that they have to find something other
people don't do I'm pumped that you're
about what you're about to tell me I
think that's great too because that's
always a great thing to do but I want to
remind everybody watching right now a
lot of people don't do things because
somebody else is already doing it and I
keep in mind people it's not about that
it's about are you better at it now did
you find something nobody else is doing
and you're great at it it's a [ __ ]
monster so I'm excited to hear what
you're about to say but that's why I did
that concept of like nobody else is
doing it has really been on my mind
because I'm like no no no no no you're
not everything's already been done stop
worrying about that just be [ __ ]
great at what you do but nonetheless go
ahead what do you want to do no no
you're right Chris I expect you to sign
up for wine tanks calm man I heard you
say that earlier and I'm like Gary's
just gonna pound me with text messages
so today well do you like wine love it
dude it's only one a day like honestly
like we literally sold a 40 every store
in the country $48 Pinot Noir yesterday
1850 a bottle free shipping like it's
this thing no no dude it's every day's a
steal it's like oh it's Groupon at its
best year one for wine and the friction
isn't seen you get the text and you just
replied for and the biggest thing are
you buying wine from somebody like some
supermarket that you don't give a [ __ ]
you actually like me and it's a better
price than the [ __ ] you're buying it
makes no [ __ ] sense hey I have some
girls and I'll get you take on this have
some some girlfriends who are in this
this clean crafted wine no headaches all
type of all that type of stuff what's
your take on it on that wine has natural
sulfites in it yep like I think it's a
market
playing I think it's working of course
it's working the brain is the most
underrated thing of all time if I tell
you you're not gonna get a headache
you're not gonna get a headache right
right
I think it's garbage wine with a good
positioning that tricks people and that
doesn't bother them either but I think
Eucharist should sign up the white
ex-con I'm in just because you said it
good all right so university town you
know the University of town I'm in hired
over a hundred faculty last year and
that's fairly high wage positions and
then there's also the it's a very
transient type of job as well so
professors faculty tenure and clinical
or transient they're always moving town
so it's it's this base that I would get
well the hiring process is very
departmental or compartmentalized so
let's just say the Business School hires
their own professors and then they would
recommend a brokerage now you can't
steer brokerage you can't steer the the
new the the new employee to a brokerage
but you can recommend but I would love
to be the brokerage of the University
and it's it's an interesting conundrum
because it's the university as a state
school and you can advertise but it's
you know twenty five fifty thousand
dollars per year to do that and that you
know being a small brokerage I don't
have the funds for that yet so but you
could you could also run pre-roll ads on
YouTube based on people searching the
University on Google and completely
crush it let me explain if you're a
professor that's coming in or if you're
just somebody considering the school a
million different variables but let's
just talk about to your point there when
I heard you say a hundred people I'm
like okay and high network and they move
around like this is good business for
you makes sense yeah um you know one of
the things you can do is Google AdWords
and YouTube pre-roll based on the
University and intercept a lot of those
people and build awareness that way and
not have the school and the 25 to 50 K
the Tollbooth but have Google be the
Tollbooth for a fraction of the price
let me yeah you got it let me give you a
pretend I'm professor Vaynerchuk you
know brown and now I'm transferring to
this place so I'm definitely gonna
Google the University that's like money
in the bank that night I go to watch a
wine video on YouTube and the pre-roll
is literally you and you're saying hey
are you going
are you considering to move to or around
Indiana University and then I'm gonna
listen to you that [ __ ] is gonna convert
like [ __ ] crazy
and you get other people by accident who
are just searching the university or a
parent who's like you know there's a
million other people you're gonna get
for a fraction of the cost
Google arbitrage all those kind of
things you just have to be good at
knowing how to target and you have to be
good at the video that converts them but
that's what you should do Chris no I
like you're giving me direction and
that's what I wanted to get with you
with I mean before I leave I got to tell
you this that I've been watching you for
a couple years which a lot of people
have but uh my wife was listening to you
one day and she was like that guy's so
loud and annoying like she goes why do
you listen to him I'm like cuz he's
always positive so I told her I was
gonna come on the show or possibly be on
the show today she owes with the loud
guy I'm like yeah with the [ __ ] loud
guy she owes Jesus I totally get it you
know like it's really fascinating my
communication style obviously makes a
lot of people love it and then there's
definitely a group that doesn't love it
but to your point what I'm proud of and
long-term what ends up happening is it's
what's being said not how it's being
said and and most of all and this has
been a theme of this whole day I just
know how to be me and do I know that if
I talked more in this tone and tenor
like I'm talking right now versus how I
get sometimes the way you do it is right
it's right because it's me right Chris
just like for you the way is right is
not to replicate me but to do it your
way and and hopefully one day I'll win
over the wife
we know what's undeniable is your paws
doesn't matter if you're talking about
12 year old or an 80 year old you're
always positive you never downplay
anybody you you appreciate their
position and that's exactly what you're
doing and I appreciate that as well I
think everybody does that's why I you so
popular so thank you listen here's my
secret plan with wine Tech's now I just
realized why I wanted you to be on it so
bad you're gonna get such a ridiculously
delicious wine for such a cheap price
you're your wife's gonna drink and be
like Chris is like the best wine I've
ever had and you'd be like the loud guy
Gary B said so love it talk to you soon
brother hi man take care
hi Susanna hi Gary
oh my god I'm such a huge fan I can't
believe that I'm actually talking to you
right now this is thank you I'm gonna
have a little moment here um thank you
so much for being who you are and just
inspiring me so much every day I I read
your first book and I'm gonna process to
do audiobooks so I'm doing the audiobook
version of it now do you like do like
that I read it I love it could you give
these like extra little things you
always go off I'm like you're like I
have to add this in because this is new
this has changed and it's just like it's
amazing I love it
um I feel like I want to ask you a
million different questions but I'm
gonna try the six to one and you kind of
covered some of the things that I've
been dealing with one of the previous
calls but I'm gonna ask anyway so I feel
like I have a lot of different interests
and I've always been this way I've
always like not really had like one
thing that I felt like I was like really
good at or that was like calling to me
and I and I feel like now I'm 33 years
old we have new kids and yeah and I just
feel like I'm not going like I'm still
kind of like moving from like one place
to the other and like trying different
things and I'm and I want to be in a
place where I'm like okay this is what
it is this is and learning like me moose
why are you tired do you think you
should or do you enjoy being a
renaissance woman you know everybody
makes this thing as a negative and I
think it's a positive but I think
society is more structure than one
school and wants kids you know my simple
question is why do you want to fight
like why is for you as a human not an
ideology or something that was put in
your head for you you why because I feel
like I won
to be great at something why maybe what
about being just great about being I'm
being serious about what I'm about to
say what about just being great in being
Susanna but what does that mean like I
don't I can't wrap my head around what
that means like it's in my mind like I
want to be like a professional or
non-professional like a expert at
something like why I don't know I know
this is a great conversation this is
what's fun about this right like like
this is why this is why I have the
enormous blessing of people following me
because I'm good at this thing of like
talking right like like I think it's
really I think it's a powerful question
like why do you need to be an expert in
something like hmm so you know and why
and how did that become an ideology and
what does it mean I mean do you want to
be an expert because that will put you
in a position to make a lot more money
without that would be a reason why
that's there's nothing wrong with that
I'm just trying to get to why you know I
think that it yes there comes the more
money aspect about the second let's talk
about that for a second I could I would
argue that that might be the whole
reason and that's more like a big chunk
and I would be okay what you'll
appreciate is if that's the case we
might be able to actually get there
through a different path which is why
I'm knocking on this door mm-hmm you
know I may be youth you know this could
be subconscious you think being an
expert or great at something will then
lead to leverage to make it financially
sound that that makes sense to me that's
logical I'm like but I would argue with
you that maybe that's not the way you
should do it like like first of all you
have to figure out how to monetize
something there's a lot of people who
are massive experts that [ __ ] that don't
make a [ __ ] dollar because they don't
know how to build a business see where
I'm going at so like I'm fearful that
the expert thing is the logical step in
your mind but then when we become an
expert at [ __ ] because we stumbled on
you being the best that makes raspberry
jam you still don't know how to [ __ ]
sell razz
I'm still gonna have that boy where I'm
gonna be still thinking that I need
something more or that ain't maybe war
war again you're putting this new
negative box I'm super proud but I do a
ton of [ __ ] I know and I hear you say
that all the time and it made me feel so
good about doing that too because I'm
like okay so Gary does that and he's
obviously very successful and a lot of
different things and you were saying how
to you it's okay to do ten different
things that's just who you are that's
what we fun and then that's how it works
for you yeah I think first of all being
a mother of two in itself is like the
[ __ ] big game right there's first of
all just it's very big it's very I have
a two and a half year old and a one year
old and it's really crazy but I feel
like I'm like chasing my tail constantly
pretty light
I want something you want you want to do
something in addition to that's amazing
yeah yeah it's not because I know
they're gonna go to school when they're
a little older and I'm gonna be like
yeah who are you as a girl like as a
little girl what were you in - um I was
in - like I don't even know like
stickers new kids on the block
oh no yeah Backstreet Boys okay question
this will give me a huge insight you
which which NSYNC Backstreet Boys or 90°
kid did you think was the cutest okay
let's bring two sweet like a sweet old
yeah and I didn't like to go and I
didn't like the the main one that like
everyone likes to kind
like the you know who's Brian wasn't
like the main one I don't think no he
was it wasn't nothing like big magic
McCord Nix yeah dreamy yeah
when I was nonetheless I am what where
I'm going with all of that is the thing
most likely is the thing that you
actually liked the most from 0 to 22 is
most likely the place where you'll find
the most success because it's predicated
on interest and passion which then means
your purse of the earth immunity top
times cuz you actually like sewing you
actually like soccer
you actually like 98 degrees and Nick
Lachey like so I'm trying to go to the
place that is your interest graph
because interests like tend to really
play out nicely in this scenario yeah I
absolutely agree with you and I think I
probably heard it from you a million
times and that's what I've been trying
to dig into so like I went to school I'm
speechless which pathologist and I think
that I pretty much did that because
that's what my parents were like you
should do that that's like a safe thing
even though right now it's not that safe
this is pandemic and we're [ __ ] not
able to actually go see patients so it's
just like that's what I did after I
graduated started working I worked in a
couple of different settings and to just
try to try to see like do I want to work
with adults who I want to work with kids
they do it like this population - I like
that population and in the meantime I
got certified as a Pilates instructor
and my husband has a physical therapy
practice so I started working with him
to try to like you know - he's a
physical therapist so physical therapy
go hand in hand I started doing some
newborn photography like I am Alyssa
please and you are you are making the
same mistake that most people make like
I'm sitting here smiling fired up and
and you think like 98% of the world
thinks that that means you're not
focused and that you like and that
you're all over to put all over all over
the place is the biggest strength and
everybody thinks it's bad because
everybody thinks like the system right
and you clearly hear you know back to
your story like if your parents are like
saying like think you like have followed
the game I get it you have demonized all
over the place yet even though following
the game you have gone out and followed
your soul and have tried tasting
different things
mm-hmm yeah proud of you I think that's
great thank you I just I kind of I don't
want to keep being a beginner at every
stop all the time you know you put
school and certification and expertise
on a pedestal and it is not no yeah no
it's not I much rather I own I'd much
rather you do 11 more things between now
and 54 and at 54 realized that you were
a horse whisperer and no nobody has a
better connection to horses than you in
the world and that you're getting paid
$50,000 to consult against horses in
[ __ ] Kentucky because when you come
and pet them and whisper to them they
run faster maybe that's your destiny
maybe but whatever I kind of wanted to
say was that I was since I was like okay
I'm a speech-language pathologist that
was just school for this let me try to
see if I can like find you know
something that happiness or joy
yes happiness in it I'm already in it
it's the thing that I have the most
experience and technically at this point
and and and so I was like the one thing
that I haven't tried yet was really
working for me so good and that's
something that I think I've always
wanted to do I remember when I was in
college my dad said what do you want to
do I was like I want to major in
business and he's like what are you
gonna do with that open up a business
like he's he was just like what I'm also
Russian he came from the former USSR I
feel like you're like my older wiser
that's why I like feel this like I love
listening to you so much and and they
have a you know mentality that you can
probably understand but your parents
were entrepreneurs my parents were not
so it's a different mentality and so I
think they were kind of very like don't
do that that's hard that's scary that's
uh no
whatever what I was discouraging my
whole life knowing the place you come
from I know that 33 is like an old bag
from where our parents came from but
listen to me it's like a 33 like if
you're not a grandma by 42 you know so I
you know I have a lot of empathy for
that listen to me your youngest buck
you clearly have entrepreneurial DNA you
should you know because of communism a
lot of your family that is your parents
parents and parents parents parents
might have been entrepreneurs but it's
not known because it was so suppressed
and so scary to do that you need to go
scratch that itch while in parallel you
need to start a baking company and do
pumpkin pies like do not say no for
yourself okay and like Instagram and
things like that like when trying to
develop a personal brand yes seeing as
that I post it's all it's okay to just
like one day post about Pilates next day
post about feeding therapy the next day
post about my kids like yes you know
because because like it's confused no
it's not confusing it's Susanna it's me
all right and that's all of those they
got it yeah many talking about the New
York Jets and garage saleing and sports
cards and that potentially is confusing
it but it's not it's who I [ __ ] in
yeah so it's all those things okay well
thank you so much um one last thing if
you can it's like a pretty general
question like just being in this moment
in time it with this pandemic is there
anything that you think is like um I
don't know just kind of like a good like
strategy that you might be if you can
even talk about it like you that you're
doing or they can get advice to anyone
else out there gratitude
yeah do you understand that this
pandemic happened
in 1991 you and I wouldn't be talking to
each other be buckets I know we wouldn't
have human connection
the Internet this is the greatest
greatest time to like reset be
thoughtful be grateful gratitude
gratitude will get everybody through
this I don't care now somebody's
watching like how do I be grateful when
I lost my job I'm like by being grateful
like you know life is twists and turns
you know that because where our families
come from there's people I I'm an
optimist I think somebody's like got
saved because of Corona because if they
were actually living in a normal life
today was the day they were gonna get
hit by car yeah
but there's a grant opportunities right
now unlimited like and yeah make content
make content make content I gotta run I
gotta get to this conference call I see
everybody thank you so much for another
episode of tea with Gary B I will be
back tomorrow 9:00 a.m.
tea with Gary if you enjoy this please
take a screenshot right now let me set
up I'd like you to take a screenshot of
this and share it on social with the
link sitting sitting giving you a chance
here please take a screenshot and tweet
it Facebook and Instagram it actually
we're gonna do this team this is what I
want to do I'm gonna take this if you're
watching screen should this take a photo
of it post it on your Instagram with
hashtag tea with Gary B post about the
show your comments how you've been
seeing it how you enjoy it but put
ashtag tea with Gary Vee post on your
Instagram my team is gonna go into the
people that post right now with that
hashtag on Instagram in a couple hours
look at everybody who did it and DM
several of you to be the questions for
tomorrow that's how we're gonna do
questions tomorrow for everybody takes a
photo of this right now and puts it in
their Facebook Instagram feed not
stories in their feed with the hashtag
tea with Gary Vee and a couple of
sentences on why they like the show why
they don't like the show whatever it is
so here we go I'm gonna set up again two
more seconds we also mentioned the fact
that some international people can't get
on community so this would be a good
opportunity for them can they hear that
what you just said no so just Dustin
just informed me that this is the
opportunity for international people to
get on because we've been taking the
questions from community my two one two
nine three one five seven three one so
now Canada Europe everybody stand up
there's your chance
putting on this story I'm tea with Gary
B tell my it's good let's see yeah
makes everybody love you guys send out
thanks team thanks Dustin see everybody
see you tomorrow
[Music]